the jurgen experience and then wednesday
all of school is closed so you know i'm
just thinking about [ __ ] what how what's
going to happen on thursday if school
opens all schools closed
and
um all new york city schools were closed
and then thursday morning i got a
decision to make because the principal
had said i was kicked out so i was like
you know what i'm just gonna walk i'm
just gonna go to school so i go back to
school and i try to walk in like nothing
happened i was like maybe they forgot
about that's a national tragedy and then
brother rob is right there he goes to
stefano get the [ __ ] out of here you're
still expelled i was like all right i
mean the country's at war now i mean my
mother fell off the bus in brooklyn
you're still going to expel me and he
was like you're expelled i was like
how's frank he was a jerk spelt i was
like okay
so i'm like [ __ ] my mother's all upset
of course she's still shaking from 9 11
as many people were i'm like i gotta
call my dad
and again my dad great guy my father
really great guy but you know a street
guy like a bronx real street guy
so i called my father for a pay phone
and i'm like dad um you know i'm sorry
like i let you down but you know on
tuesday i was just worried about my mom
and his kids started laughing at me i
was crying and i broke a chair over this
kid frank's head and and now they threw
me out they threw me out of school and
he goes uh he goes did anybody see you
do it i was like yeah i did in front of
the whole class he was like okay he was
like um i'll be down there in about 30
minutes i was like you live on he lives
in staten island
you know traffic to queens at 9 30 in
the morning would take like two hours to
get there somehow he shows up in like 45
minutes i'll never forget wearing like a
new york yankees batting practice jacket
like a son like a dunkin donuts coffee
huge chain on just ready to go and he
goes um you do everything i tell you to
do i was like okay
so
we you need a meeting with a principal
you know of a school especially any
school
but we walk into the principal's office
to the secretary and the secretary is
like can i help you my dad's like yeah i
got a meeting with the principal and
she's like you're not on the list sir he
goes i'm going in and then he just opens
his door
and the principal's on the phone
and my dad goes can i speak to you can
we speak to you i'm chris's dad and the
principal's like um you need a meeting
sir and he goes and your son's expelled
and he goes uh okay and then he hangs up
the principal's phone he just puts his
fingers on the receiver and he goes
you're not on the phone anymore so we
can have a conversation and i was like
oh my god so it's all true so i'm just
sitting there like okay this is bad so
my dad goes
very calmly my dad goes listen he goes
my son allegedly hit somebody in the
head with the chair and brother's like
it's not a legend we saw it he goes it's
allegedly you don't have cameras in here
do you and he was like what he was like
no but there's witnesses and the kids in
the hospital he goes i'll take care of
the kid in the hospital don't worry
about the kid in the hospital he goes
you can't throw my son out of school you
just can't do it and then my brother rob
is like we have to throw your son out of
school he just hits put somebody in a
coma and he goes no he goes listen
i could throw him out of school it was a
national tragedy he got emotional don't
worry about it and he goes don't throw
him out of school and brother said
brother rob says i'm throwing him out of
school and there's nothing you can do
and then my dad rolls like a wad of
hundreds at brother rob and he goes
don't throw him out of school and
brother rob goes you're gonna bribe a
man of god and my dad goes i lost god
september 21st 1979. that's like a date
that's like burned in my head i'm like
what the [ __ ] what does that date mean
and then look back he was in prison at
that time so i'm like i don't know what
happened maybe there was a shower
situation maybe something went down i
was like i'm not gonna ask my dad but i
was like september 21st 1979 wow like he
said that [ __ ] quick and with full eye
contact no blinks i was like all right
dad you got you should go to therapy but
whatever we're here now
and
so
so my dad says to brother rob he goes
listen he goes
don't throw my son out of school okay
there has to be another way let's talk
like gentlemen there has to be another
way and then he says to my father go sir
are you stupid or something he's
expelled from school
and then my dad looks at me
and he looks at brother rob and he goes
chris did he did he just call me stupid
and i was like you know
it sounded like a dad but you know he's
he's a man of god i'm sorry i was like
no no habla no obligates and he goes um
do me a favor chris lock the door
and i was like what he goes just lock
the door
and so i got up and locked the door i
didn't know like what else to do i was
like oh i was like i felt like i'm
[ __ ] gonna get hit here too like my
i've never seen my dad like this just
angry so i get up i lock the door and he
goes
you really offended me with the words
you've chose to call him to call me
because it really hurt my feelings
actually he goes so now you have two
options he goes the second option really
sucks for you i would choose the first
he goes the first option
just put my son back in school okay easy
breezy no problems ass i'll sign
whatever forms you want he goes back to
school he goes the second option and
again this one sucks for you he goes i'm
gonna come over there and i'm gonna
break both your kneecaps and he goes you
may think i heard that line in a movie
he goes i'm one of the guys they write
the movies about he goes i will and this
is funny he goes i will call 9-1-1 right
now he goes i will give them my address
my social security number whatever he
goes because i'd rather go to prison for
the rest of my life and be back with my
friends then you throw him out and me
have to listen to his mother's [ __ ]
mouth for the rest of my life that he
got expelled from school he goes so
either way i'm in jail i'd rather be
with my buddies so the choice is yours
and then white as a ghost
brother rob was like
okay well let's let's put him back in
school and he goes simple easy breezy he
just kept saying easy breezy my dad i
was like stop saying easy breezy so he
kept saying easy breezy and my dad and
he goes uh he goes what we'll do is he
gets detention before and after school
and he's thrown off the basketball team
does that work for you brother rob was
like that works for me and i was like
that doesn't [ __ ] work for me i want
to play ball i want to go to detention
and my dad's like no you hit somebody
it's not good he goes who i i didn't
raise you to be that way i was like you
just threatened to [ __ ] kill somebody
in front of me what are you talking
about
and he goes i didn't raise you to be
that way and then that's what i did my
senior year before and after school
every day um no basketball
and my father and brother rob actually
became like
friends at
graduation they were shaking hands
friends everything was all good and it
was one of those things where like
my dad he's not that way anymore but
growing up like my dad was just that guy
he was like right intention wrong move
is the best way i could describe my
father